The jogan
Experience what a stupid world we're
living in I can't wait for mind reading
Bring it on Bring It On expose
everyone Joe we cannot have mind reading
plus legal acid we can fix this mind
reading is bad mind reading is going to
result in your woman is in a women are
going to be
segregated why why if you brought dude
what would happen if you meet your your
best friend's wife
and in your head's like yeah I'd like to
[__] her from behind like and then they
know
about to have to learn how to curb those
thoughts homeboy never going to
happen
happen this is what it'll be this is
what it be there'll be like many layers
of what a thought is there's a thought
about it has to categorize but the early
days when it's like Mark comes in
dressed nice shaving I'm like oh [__]
that wait what but it's you are the gay
one dude I knew you nasty and gay have
you seen this what is this this is a
movie with Tom Holland and Daisy Ridley
who was in uh Star Wars they they the
Sci-Fi thing is it's explaining what you
guys are talking about men men's
thoughts are out loud and women's are
not in this movie I thought it was very
interesting but what you're saying is
what is happening well Chappelle had
that old bit when he was 14 sounds like
a little [__] in this movie that's
hilarious
she ran away they're in the woods he's
like I'd like to hold her down and [__]
it no no no just one part of
me's trying to talk you [__] animals
should bit when he's 14 about how
superheroes he's like you know what if
black or Batman went to a black
neighborhood where's the car Robin
whatever but he had a great bit about uh
Wonder Woman has a lasso of Truth so if
she scooped you up you'd be like nice
tits that was when he was 14 yeah but
it's true that's what we would think
yeah if you could do mind reading we'd
be
[__] would we be but isn't the problem
is that we can't read minds like
shouldn't people adjust the way they
think about things no you can't help it
I bet you can't if technology arises
here's the thing we think
that's what about are you willing to
give up Google on your phone are you
willing to give up Google on your phone
you're not Google is fine yeah you're
going to get to the next Google the next
Google is mind reading Joe what no way
if in your head get in there Bro Look
[Music]
Around lot meat recipes hold on I really
am pretty consistent cook meat so oh
here's another jalapeno steak a hot lady
really into reverse here but a hot lady
comes up to you a hot lady hot lady
walks up imagine looks directly into
your mind you're not
going nice
literally every single part is
like if if we get deal with it if we get
M reading right every single woman is
what a hot lady walks up to you and goes
I think I don't have to work anymore if
I that would be that too that too
whatever she looks goes like this guy
like he's a sweet gun yeah I don't think
we need technology for that I could make
myself love him imagine married woman on
a treadmill and then you look over and
you're like oh there's Jerry
Seinfeld maybe I don't have
with get that looking out online I can
suck his dick into a full future yeah
that's going to be a thing it's so easy
we're so vulnerable cuz we're all like
like women are so like a hot woman like
a really hot woman is so [__]
powerful take it easy anyone else hard
really J why' you just say like when you
see Lauren Sanchez and Jeff Bezos you're
like I get it yeah and they know too
who's the who's the chck from
Transformers Megan Fox oh yeah just like
you can do whatever you want with
anybody yeah St Ros was talking about
her the other day oh it's like yeah like
like
angular just like like Superior genetics
like eyes why are you talking slow and
soft yeah why you trying to get as hard
yeah come on Jo I'm going to take these
headphones off if you keep talking
sexual sorry boys who just who just did
the uh Transformer
voice what voice you guys to do that
your head budy oh that was me sorry all
right nice that was good I just [__]
around but yeah we can't have too much r
a little ignorance is bliss you need a
little bit of yeah but that's not going
to happen man I'm telling you that's the
bottleneck the bottleneck is end of
society you'll need some it be so bad
it'll be way worse we think social media
is bad we think social media is bad
where we're like everybody shouldn't be
talking the last thing I want is to
bring my
girlfriend around my friends and listen
to my friend's thought of like I'd [__]
her I'd [__] her I'd [__] her of course
or how about this I wouldn't [__] her
would also be terrible yeah how about
how tell you
what AR pronounce I've never heard a
better Ari yeah whatever
uh that's I mean that's that's the worst
yeah you bring a hot you think all these
guys wait why why does that guy not and
then a guy you bring your girl around
the guy goes
e you go well I'm I have to kill
him